hello my name is David chan azan and
research intern at King Abdullah
University of Science and Technology and
I'm going to present about symbolic PD
analysis with using Mathematica and this
is research
it's joint work with the ogle Gomez and
Mary Sofia
hello I'm David Jonathan I'm researched
internet King Abdullah University of
Science and Technology and I'm going to
talk about symbolic bidding analysis
using Mathematica this is joint work
with do commerce and mercifully on and
the architecture of the talk I will say
of course the motivation previous work
and the key functions that we have
implemented the basic functions and
after what we built within these basic
functions what complicated and complex
things you have we have been doing with
this basic functions and the most some
motivation in physics conserved and
dissipation laws describes the
conservation of dissipation of
fundamental physical quantities such as
misanthropy linear momentum and energy
and these computations by to do by hand
often and are really hard to do that's
why we are working on automation and
also for nonlinear PDS the in principle
infinite number of the conservation
quantities lets us to be sure that we
have complete integrability the thing is
that when in the in the scheme of the
numerical solution if we have already
concerned finally found conserved
quantities we can see in this scheme of
the numerical solution at first part in
the medium and in the last if this
concern if these quantities are the tank
can say conserved that means that our
numerical solution is not is true it's
working by a correct way okay let's go
forward
okay
and the problem we want to solve is to
find the dissipation conservation laws
for a nonlinear system nonlinear PDEs
system or of single PD and for
simplicity let's consider one PD where
the X is the high dimensional variable
in periodical domain and UX is the set
of partial derivatives with respect to
that variables and we want to find the
expressions and functions of the form Y
for which the time derivative of
integral of U is equal to the zero and
it's conservation law and the integral u
is more than or equal to the some
constant or the time derivative of that
integral is less than equal to zero
dissipation law we want to find such
laws and as a simple example let's look
to the heat equation and so to find
conservation of energy and here is the
time derivative of the integral u X T
and we can take the derivative inside of
the integral and after use the
right-hand side of the heat equation and
after doing integration we will get this
part which is equal to the zero and we
will get that the energy is conserved
and this quantity is concerned let's go
to the it's not
okay and some similar computations we
will get that these quantities can
dissipate it okay let's go forward and
there we are the not the only one who
are working on this there were guys who
did some papers about finding
conservation laws for specific PDS on a
nonlinear PDS and also solving some over
determined systems okay let's go and I
want to talk about the simple task what
we are doing we are generating just
money monomials or polynomials
integrating by parts we are cleaning now
lagrangians after simplifying integral
identities and the Proctor applying
Kahler lagrange operator and finding
undetermined coefficient matrix we we
are and after we are solving the there's
some equation we will see and we are
getting the consult anticipated
quantities the thing is we have
implemented some basic operations and
within this basic operation we can do
some hard and complex stuff what we will
show what I will show to find the
concert anticipated quantities and let's
talk about euler lagrange operator or
the same as variation derivative here we
have some expression u and integral
expression is of expression is equal to
0 its equivalent that we will apply to
this expression the euler lagrange
operator and we will call this no
lagrangian and we here we can see the
form of euler lagrange operator in one
dimensional case and my multi
dimensional case in two dimensional case
the signal okay let's go forward and
using this alloy large operator we can
define the time derivative
and we will take time derivative inside
of the integral and after using a chain
rule from calculus we will get this part
and after we can see that it's the same
as or that we apply to the expression
euler lagrange operator with multiplied
UT and the UT we will take the right
side of the equation right hand side of
the equation f and now we can state the
final result we which we need for
further research here is EU is conserved
if this expression is equal to 0 and U
is dissipated if this integral is more
than one constant and this integral is
less than 0 less than or less or equal
to zero ok let's go forward and here is
the variation derivative function both
from researchers built in function
variational derivative D in the
variation method packets but we have
implemented for us because it's B this
one is much faster just you will see
results for example here is one
dimensional case here is one more
example in two dimensional case and with
now a more complex one with two
dependent variables ok let's go forward
and here is our one of the our basic
functions monomial generation and what
it does it generates monomial lead with
respect to dependent independent
variables maximum degree
maxime derivative order of derivative
and let's see for example maximum
degrees to unboxing derivative order is
for here's the generated monomials and
we can change to be even then the degree
the whole of the whole expression
okay and here we have we can we have a
parameter we can have parameter
generators which lets us to generate
model monomials with respect to these
generators for example here you can see
and one more example with other
generators
you are the monomials you know using
these generators and one more example
and here we can see that we are with
respect to you and we dependent X
independent variables the maximum degree
in derivative or the maximum order of
derivative is 2 and generators are
specified okay let's go forward and for
polynomial generation we have
implemented a function which we here is
the fine symmetric group what it does as
a parameter it takes the system of the P
DS and dependent and independent
variables and it's finds the symmetric
group of this system of P DS and let's
see the system symmetric group and here
you can see that the possible
permutations between and it finds
discrete symmetries discard symmetry
group and possible permutations between
dependent variables the between the
equations P DS and also independent
variables and so parity symmetries the
sign changes and what we can do by using
this function we can generate all the
polynomials which are symmetric under
the group which solutions are symmetric
under the group the group of this
discrete symmetries and here let's see
and these generated polynomials are
symmetric under the group of the system
of PD specified here and as we are
working on the on periodical domain the
integration by parts looks like this in
the pedicle domain and let's see some
examples of integration by parts we have
implemented this function for example in
one-dimensional case in two-dimensional
case and here is more complex example by
going further and we need with using
this function we are deleting all the
null aggressions from the list of some
terms and what is done now LeGrand
chantix the term which the integral of
this term is equal to the 0 because we
should clean to have more to be able to
do computation faster and here is one
sorry
I don't know which
okay and here is it cleaned nah nah
Lagrange from the list here is one more
example there were all nocturnal
aggression it cleaned old and here is
one it left one which is not not laganja
and here is more compaction but more
complex what it does it removes all the
terms from the expression which are now
Lagrange's not from the list from the
expression complexity for example from
this part it removes Alden
Nullah gratias all the terms which form
together now laganja and here is one
more example and here is two-dimensional
case it says that everything was
non-aggression the expression and we
have function undetermined coefficient
matrix and let see for example we have
the expression and we want what we are
doing here we we are defining in the
different form then it has because we
should for example this is this
expression is equal to the zero we shall
find the parameters in the conditions of
the parameters where this expression is
or equal to the zero and what we assume
that that terms which are dependent on U
and V dependent variables of our
nonlinear PDEs are linearly independent
and as they are linearly independent
their multipliers should be 0 to 2 for
the whole expression to be 0 and we will
use and its defines this undetermined
coefficient matrix and we will see how
we use that for finding dissipated and
conserved
and for finding concert' conservation
laws as I said in the tasks part there
are some basic functions we are using we
are generating monomers and polynomials
we are constructing general general form
of the density we are computing the time
derivative and after we will determine
the unknown constant coefficients and we
will solve with respect to them to find
the quantities which we want conserved
quantities and here are the functions
which you are using for each step okay
let's see some example for example
cadivi equation let's generate monomials
for that also we can generate symmetric
polynomials with find symmetric group
with as short and strictly symmetric
polynomials with respect to the group
but we will go with simpler one with
monomials and here we are cleaning in a
Lagrangian and let's see the number
became there were 15 laganja's and we
are generating coefficients constructing
coefficient and construct in general
form and what we will do we defined in
the theory that it how we find the
conserved quantities and now we are
using that theory part two and using the
euler lagrange operator and we applied
that and now we will find undetermined
coefficient matrix here is the matrix
and what we will do we will solve with
with respect to the parameters to find
the conditions which we need for the
expression to be conserved
and here is the conditions and we if we
apply to the general form these
conditions we will get this that this
expression is concerned with respect to
the Khedive equation for the kadhi a
vacation is conserved quantity and also
we have complex function with more
possible parameters it's conserved
quantity and for this case it does the
same it finds the conserved quantity
what do I don't get okay it goes
which wouldn't be so
let's see the pen is working the penis
work okay
it gave and also for example we have
implemented one function with tests if
this expression is concerned or not and
if you put testing true we will get true
or false in case two it's we have done
four tests testing and let's go forward
it we will see that it work okay and
here examples with hate equation
I don't want to say that it's all the
bad maybe
okay
and here are some examples we had heat
equation which finds the conserved
quantities
okay and it's a three-dimensional case
but I will not execute that because it
will take time it works and here is four
more examples with me field games the
first one is hamilton-jacobi equation
and second one is transport equation in
more general case it for kerplunk and
let's find the conserved quantities of
this me feel games of the speed is okay
and here is another example of mean
filled games
the okay this is this expression is
concerned and also wave equation we have
now we wrote in with two systems of P
this is the simple is the simple
transformation from wave equation to the
system of P DS together they are the
wave wave equation and I will not
execute the causes I don't know why it
takes time and ok let's find dissipation
laws and short ways here is with resolve
Mathematica built-in function to find
the soup dissipation laws and here's
problems that we will get with this
function for example for nonlinear
expressions let's see what not it say
that it didn't find the result also
false with this kind of and also with
high order expressions it's it's it is
not finding it giving some bad result
which we don't want to see okay and
let's go for the function we have
implemented its general positivity and
for polynomial cases and its finds the
necessary and sufficient conditions for
being positive the expression and here
is one more example and for non
polynomial cases were finding we can
find enough with just a sufficient
conditions and let's see here and here
are more eggs
one more example also this one and also
we have a case which finds the
asymptotic positivity asymptotic is it
finds the conditions for being positive
just with higher for the higher order
and
[Music]
order terms of the higher and lower
order terms of the expression and with
the higher and or lower degrees of the
expression with the terms with respect
to the terms let's see it finds the
conditions
and also by simplifying this in with
respect to the conditions we have got
with positivity function we can use no
positivity basic function with just
result function get conditions to be
preserved to be positive and here is one
example with heat equation
Kayla generate monomials let's clean
Allah grants from the monomials list of
monomials and we will construct the
general form and we will do time there
we will apply euler lagrange operator to
the general general form and also we
will multiply with the right-hand side
of the equation as it was shown in the
theory for the dissipation laws and we
will castle now Lagrangian integrated we
will integrate by parts to have more
symmetric terms the to be able to have
more symmetric terms to work with
because it will be easier for us
and now just removing the diamond the
denominators and we will find the
positivity conditions it works like two
minutes I will not here is the
conditions of the positivity for this
equation for this expression and we will
just have more complex form of these
conditions in table form and by
simplifying the general form with
respect to conditions we will get that
this is dissipated and here is the terms
of our expression which is dissipated
low for our four heat equation and
conclusions we have found conserved
quantities dissipated quantities with
using some basic functions and for now
what we are doing we are working on over
the term in system solver and what we
are doing we are removing from the list
right now we are working on removing
redundant PDS from the system of P DS
and with using that we will go for
finding Li symmetry is and so on point
symmetries and thank you
you
[Applause]